I absolutely love the show and one of
the so many great ideas in the show but
you do play the last man on earth or it
opens you think you're the last man on
earth
yep and and it's very well handled that
everyone on earth is gone there's this
one guy it's you you're driving all
around the country taking whatever you
want doing whatever you want and one of
the things you do which is the
consummate guy thing is you're just
wearing underwear because no one's
around and I thought that was kind of
genius cuz that's kind of what a guy
would do yeah I assume so I mean it you
know some people say well wouldn't why
would you even wear underwear then you
know but but I think there's you know
sun protection that's the answer that I
know you're worried about the sun
protection but did you ever think about
having your character go completely
naked just walk around nude no no you
don't know my my anatomy taken two ways
either yeah either you're not yet either
you don't know my anatomy no there's you
know there there's the phrase it's a
grower not a shower yeah but it's not a
grower or a shower it's consistent I'll
give it that
yeah you shave your body once didn't you
I did I well mainly I did it for 30 rock
once okay to show 30 rock and I played
you know Jenna Jenna's boyfriend
boyfriend who is a female impersonator
of her right essentially she's dressing
herself so I would shave my body for
work and it was fine but I'm I'm proud
of my I'm proud of my my body hair for
out of bed but there was there was there
was one time in my personal life that I
did do a shave job
I'm shaved your body for your personal
life was this something that like your
girlfriend preferred or something well
it was for a girlfriend she had been
away for a long a long period of time
working and I thought it would be a
romantic gesture to kind of shave this
area kind of lends itself to the the
shape of an arrow so I shaved it I
helped it along with the razor and
shaved an arrow
morning you did her antic and love it
was gone she lost IQ points yeah doesn't
feel right this is like get to work you
know that's like hey remember remember
me you know let's reconnect so you just
you you shaved it an arrow I didn't
believe this I heard about this earlier
today I didn't believe it and then you
were determined that we believe you so
you brought an actual photograph
probably yeah from this period of your
oh my god
[Applause]
we broke up like two weeks I don't know
if it had something to do with that I
think it had something to do with that
might've she left you because you did
that it was not it it was a bad move
you